and it is here it is here free agent
sale I thought you were talking about
spring forward we were moving the clocks
up that totally [ __ ] my life up how
can you call us so excited how can you
call it spring forward when it's winter
still no it's fine now but now we get
more sunlight at the end of the day it's
a trade-off that's worth it I wasn't
ready for it why mess me up
what did you have to oh you're such a
mess that my sleep my sleeping patterns
operate on a strict schedule of seven
and a half hours I wake up I feed the
chickens I go downstairs I eat yeah it
really throw off your robot skip we lost
the chicken I'm sorry yeah I don't know
is either a kind of out there simcha
coyote or a fox some came out and you
just found a carcass we found a trail of
feathers and your daughter now is at a
point of dr. Quinn Medicine Woman where
she understands she's cyclic rail right
she tried to find what it was you know
what we should have done slice what we
should have said we've got breaking news
Sims has lost a chicken this will be the
new sound that comes on when we are
going to break news deep 2g we are
recording this it is about 350 on Monday
the legal tampering period starts at
4:00 and as any information comes out I
have Noah and I have Lee and they are in
my slack right now and if anything comes
down there messaging me direct and I
will play that news music to break in
with anything interesting awesome are
you excited I am excited I don't know if
this news periods gonna be is exciting
as we're all anticipating to like I got
something for you
here we go Alex miss money is coming out
apparently fifty five million is
guaranteed by signing 71 million
guaranteed by the start of 2019 meaning
that he is getting more than Jimmy
Garoppolo and slightly less than
Stafford he's getting 71 million
guaranteed by the start of 2019 so he's
getting 35 million a year
Wow are you kidding me Alex that's why
this Kurt cousins now that's gonna throw
a wrench into whoever's negotiating with
that without a doubt so awesome so we're
gonna be breaking in but honestly a lot
of stuff happened this weekend yes want
to give a quick shout out to the Jaguars
out there whatever drugs you still got
two days you could still have Blake
bortles do his is physical and you can
cut them you don't have to give them the
conscious not a jerk we're just talking
business talking business lairs podcast
that's what we do
alright so before we get going you came
up to me and said I actually have some
news nuggets yeah I want to say this
we're recording this before the
tampering period ends if Simms is right
Oracle we told you so first one Allen
Robbins right who are you hearing is
interested in Allen Robin Allen Robinson
I hear it's down to a two-team race and
again I don't know these things for sure
but I've heard these from good yeah I
know a few people I have been told that
Allen Robinson it's going to be the
Green Bay Packers or the Chicago Bears
both would be extremely interesting
moves right cago bears I go makes a lot
of sense sure Green Bay I'm going Aaron
Rodgers Davante Adams so they just
locked up right Allen Robinson does that
mean Jordy would be gone I think or a
Randall Cobb it could be either one it
could be both it really could but either
way they do need an upgrade of the
position we know that well guess what
Sims apparently story has come out that
Rodgers and Jimmy Graham have been
talking throughout the offseason huh huh
there's a chance that tight end could be
hitting the Green Bay to who would not
shock me either I would think the Bears
are gonna be in that net the mix for him
as well I want to talk Rogers the
greatest quarterback we've ever seen who
do you like more Robinson or Jimmy
Graham wow that's a really good one for
him for him mmm
man I can't believe Green Bay is
interested in free agency the Ted
Thompson era is officially over it's
over because I got another name for you
coming up soon too but who do you like
more between those two I mean I get into
Rob getting Rodgers some size in the red
zone like they both have like the things
I think of right away like Graham's not
a great run blocker so he's not gonna
help
huge huge part of the office that way
but he is such a target down the middle
of the field or red zone doesn't really
with the guy like Rogers it doesn't
matter if he's ever open again in their
history of his life Allen Robinson I
think is maybe the more talented point
guy at this point of his career so
worried about the AC I do I mean yes who
is the other Green Bay thing you're
hearing the other Green Bay thing I'm
hearing is true Maine Johnson remain
Johnson from from from my sources they
tell me that that that has become Kansas
City Green Bay and an outside chance
with the Cleveland Browns the tremaine
Johnson you have them as a top-five
corner obviously not going back to the
ranch I have a keep to leave it Marcus
Peters without to that in a second too
but you're saying it's between Green Bay
and Kansas City yes for Jermaine Johnson
Kansas City obviously needs one yes
and then Green Bay they got rid of
damarious Randall as well so they both
need to definitely I mean lost Sam
Shields a few years ago to the
concussion issues they've needed a
shutdown type corner anyways really for
for a number of years they really
haven't had that guy interest so that
would make a lot of sense Kansas City I
mean of course it's gonna make sense
there to him and and Kendall fuller
together on the outside you're also
combo what about Malcolm Butler Malcolm
Butler I am being told that that is a
pretty much a sure thing to the Detroit
Lions now maybe somebody else comes in
here and and saves the day or steals on
the way but that omit that makes sense
and I heard a patrician is interested
make sense to of course yes but you
think Detroit pretty much which makes me
think that it raises so many questions
about the decision not to play him this
tells me that Bill Belichick might have
been just him right and Bob Quinn and
Patricia are like Malcolm Butler we need
you it's interesting well I mean you you
really I feel like at this point if
Malcolm Butler had done something so
egregiously wrong that we would have
heard from somebody one of the Patriots
players but I let it out of the bag
right something I operate well I just
feel like some even the free agent who
might not be back we would have heard
the story the fact that Brady like liked
his thing on you know Instagram or
Twitter or whatever it is all those
clues lead me to believe that a lot of
these guys did not think he should have
been benched
you believe from what you told me
earlier you could see the Rams making a
play to get Sammy Watkins yep I do think
he's still very much in there and you
believe what's awful oh could be looking
at Case Keenum as number one right and
Bradford is number chest number two and
I and I hear that Kirk Cousins is the
favorite to Minnesota certainly but so
much so is in the keenham race Kirk
Cousins penned a thank you letter to
Washington and you're not going to
understand this because you don't
understand the Internet when you get
done writing a blog or I post on YouTube
there are things called tags and what
you do is it's keywords so when I push
that put this on to YouTube I'm gonna
write NFL free agency Kirk Cousins
whatever well Kirk Cousins on his
thank-you letter in the tags Vikings all
no other team it says Washington Thank
You bow ah Vikings Wow you put that in
there so that if anyone searches for
Vikings your letter comes up all right
so some other news though
Chiefs cut Tom Bosley yep and they also
cut our guy Ron partner Ron Parker for
people that haven't been paying
attention to the podcaster Sims al of
core for a while was like one of the
original hidden truths yeah back when
they had like eight safeties it was
who's this Ron Parker guy right the Ron
Parker era has ended I feel like part of
getting them paid I think we had to do
these all different people listen out
there we like an old bleacher report we
do these like team fits team needs in
Lefko and I would do just videos for
certain teams to say look for this free
agency to come to Kansas City or this
for you we always like Ron Parker could
fix everything and I but Ron Parker like
every team that needed a safety alright
so again as the news happens we are now
three minutes away from four o'clock
three minutes I will be pounding this
noise pound um if there is any breaking
news very excited and again Noah and
Leigh on the case they're telling me
right now that Jonathan Stewart is
expecting to visit the Giants after
meeting with the lion
that's the odds doer dose all right the
big news I think over the weekend though
we'll get the Browns to but the 49ers
get Richard Sherman you had spoken to
Kyle Shanahan you had heard from your
friend our favorite coach of the NFL
that the whole going after Talib thing
was real it was real yes it definitely
was they wanted to keep to leap for sure
there's no doubt about that
but I think the big thing there that
came down to more than anything was the
fact that when I keep Talib he's being
traded right yes and so he has a little
power in that situation and of course he
had the power in this situation to kind
of be like like he said be the
disgruntled all you're gonna trade me
here well then I might not show up so
Elway had to find partners and he know
what keep to leave was going to go a
cute to leave was telling people this
listen if I was if I was a free agent I
would have signed with anybody because
he'd get a chance to come and meet with
coaches right you get a meeting room you
have dinner you get to talk about
contract options you get on the
chalkboard and talk football a little
bit so you get to know people but their
trade you don't so I understand that
being a fear so he says I want to go to
New England where I've been or to Denver
or excuse me to the Rams where Wade
Phillips is where I want to super play
exactly right if I'm being traded I want
to go to somewhere where I know the
people and know what I'm getting into
and that's why you heard the rumors that
New England of course was in the
conversation ultimately it ended up
being the Rams
it sounds like players enjoy talking to
your friend Kyle I mean I would think
Sherman had a nice dinner with him yeah
well I mean Kyle and yes Kyle and Lynch
are gonna be able to relate to players
better than most coaches and GM's and
there are also the type of guys like
we're seeing with it Richard Sherman or
we're gonna keep Talib that they're not
afraid to take a chance on the renegade
a little bit yes I mean John Lynch came
from the Tampa Bay Buccaneers that
defense was full of renegades so he's
not looking for choirboys across the
board Kyle doesn't care and Kyle as long
as total misfit off the field making
issues yeah and he believes that you
love football then he can make it work
more badass duo at cornerback as just
like a shit-talking kind of guy
Talib and Marcus Peters or Jalen Ramsay
and AJ Bowie oh man
because to Leoben Peters I have a quote
here from a keep to lead that makes me
very excited yes he said with that
market
speaking about la where Wade Phillips
with a young energetic corner on the
other side man to bring that youth to me
a great quarter I could Todd Gurley it's
a great situation the fact that he said
to bring that youth to me the fact that
he's sitting there going Marcus Peters
gonna give me that energy back right and
I go
Talib is gonna be even more ridiculous
so to leave in Peters Ramsey I feel like
is Ramsey best yes it right he's the
best [ __ ] talker right we're gonna give
him the time nobody gets underneath the
skin of receiver so he's number one but
you're right two three might be a key
yeah and Peter's dynamic duo it's gonna
be awesome
and that's why guys love playing for
Wade Phillips too Wade Phillips can
rally the troops fires just he's another
guy that's relatable and they listen to
him and they're gonna do what he says
the fact that he has two corners at that
level
yes what does that do for the rest of
that defense in LA does it allow them to
lose a no goal tree and a Quinn I think
so too and it's a defense to where I
think where he looks at it and goes I
can find some athletes in the middle
there and we get guys like LaMarcus
Joyner who we franchise who will be in
the middle they already have the you
know the mark berry right so they have
the kind of guys he already wants to
play in the middle of the defense I'm
sure they have a few hidden gems that he
wants but either way yes
I mean to me when you make moves like
that it's gonna make everybody and hold
their whole division reor castrate what
they want to do like I would think most
teams are going damn what's the point of
if you're in the NFC Western what's the
point of us really signing a big time
free agent wide receiver right now maybe
we need to get tight ends and
linebackers and just when we play the
Rams we'll work on that part of their
defense and the hell was the tires and
keep Talib right because you don't
really want to mess with right so
Richard Sherman signs a three-year 39
million dollar deal right but again
we've tried to explain it to you guys
over the years only look at the
guarantee
money is the only thing that matters
what's interesting about Richard
Sherman's deal there are so many bonuses
and qualifiers his contract next year is
a two million dollar base to make the
full thirty-nine he's got to be an
all-pro for three seasons and play 90
percent of the snaps right how important
is it to have an agent Joe Thomas
literally just came out on Twitter and
said you feel really bad for Richard
Sherman but this is clearly a case of
ego getting in the way of his pocketbook
he got absolutely crushed on this
contract while working as his own agent
when you heard the details did you agree
with that sentiment yeah well I agree
there's a lot of things that were
alarming to me right am I just the the
simple the simple fact of how quickly he
signed with the team what was the rush
create a market for yourself go out of
15 in the Peter King article it said
that he knew that if he left some of it
was gonna come off the table and he
didn't want to risk that right but
that's the thing when you have an agent
the aging and go and talk to other no
doubt about it they're gonna do they're
gonna gauge the market and really you
know I don't know if I believe that
either who knows what I mean what what
the three million dollars that they're
gonna give them was off the bat I mean
they got like ninety million dollars so
I I have a hard time believing that but
I would say this you know first of all
when he had no agent that bled both of
us to believe he's gonna go to teams
where he feels there's a familiarity
with the defense right we talked about
the 49ers being one of those 239 errs
Atlanta Jack Sevilla Lausanne so right
away he was gonna go to those type of
teams to talk about oh this is your
scheme so from the 49ers standpoint I'll
say this I think it's a great it's a
great signing right you have young
defense you need a guy due to maybe show
your other young corners the intricacies
of the Seattle defense what Richard
Sherman's meant he's gonna bring a
little attitude a little leadership I
think they're a team that can handle
that like we talked about with Shannon I
think he can handle you know the strong
personality of a Richard Sherman so from
that best they needed a leader they have
all these draft picks Rd line and a
young guy and Reuben Foster and they
needed a new leader yes and I think he's
the guy he came by question is this for
you yeah so much of his money was locked
up in Pro Bowls right I don't know the
language of his contract
but when Derek Carr makes the Pro Bowl
this year isn't
easy to make the pro-bowl also could the
NFLPA
somewhat collude with each other if all
of these players have Pro Bowl
qualifiers in their contracts why don't
all the best players just go no I'm not
gonna go and then we you open out like
if Patrick Peterson makes the Pro Bowl
over Richard Sherman and knows that
Richard Sherman's gonna get eight
million dollars and a guaranteed
contract next year Camp Patrick Peterson
Goyo I'm not gonna do yeah you know I'm
not gonna lie I'm not exactly sure how
all that language works too because they
might be being a replacement in the Pro
Bowl might not actually qualify if
that's my question so that's because I
just thought it's so easy to get to the
Pro Bowl and my thing is but even then
why would you want why would you want
your money locked up and something that
you don't have any control over right
you're gonna let your money be
determined by a fan vote and then all
pro media like it's not statistics and
all that stuff no I know you're letting
other people dictate your madness stars
have that kind of thing built like
Patrick Peterson he'd probably go well
no because I'm bidding even though I got
paid nine million dollars this year I'm
getting an extra five hundred thousand
because I made the Pro Bowl so I'm not
gonna sit it out just a Richard Richard
Sherman can get his 7 million unless
Richard cut you a check that's a great
deal but I do believe listen players
without a contract this is the second
time it's coming in with Lamar Jackson
Richard sure right there's there's
benefits here I understand guys don't
want to pay the 3 percent but in the
long run the 3 percent is nothing I
think for what the agent can do and
again Richard Sherman who I know is an
intelligent person and well-thought-out
and understands the league but I'm sorry
you know him going to the negotiating
table with the people that are
negotiating for the San Francisco 49ers
it's like them going out and trying to
get wide open against him when he's
playing DB on the field this is their
area of expertise yeah what would make
you believe that you're gonna like
out-compete them at that to that point
right I was reading Peter Kings article
and the guy was like I'll be honest he
really came prepared I was like oh the
Niners are just gassing him up so he
doesn't feel bad about it all I know is
this
if Richard Sherman is an all-pro and he
ends up getting the 11 to 13 million
dollars a year because he comes back
like that it's a win-win for everybody
but right now look he's betting on
himself he wants to play we love Richard
Sherman right I hope he does get all-pro
and all
maybe those questions where his lower
body's gonna be you're right he might be
really worried about laughing on damn I
might not Chili's are hard Yeah right I
got three million in the bank now no
matter what I'm looking at the sheet and
it says or the slack room and it says
eerily quiet right now I'm telling you
it's gonna be quiet you think so because
I don't think these free agents are in
this demand as people think that's you
actually think that's part of the reason
why trades one I do I think the reason
we've seen a lot of big trades is
because a lot of these teams are looking
at it and going damn am I really gonna
pay Sammy Watkins like close to Antonio
Brown money no people don't want to do
that people don't want to pay Tremayne
Johnson like he's Darrelle Revis and his
prime and they're all good players and
I'm thinking anything buddy's denying
that right but I just think just because
of the year and it's oh this is the next
market price up for freedom really likes
I think some teams are kind of renig in
on that and going like I don't really
want to be forced in that corner to
where I have to pay let's say a Kendall
for for the Chicago Bears who is awesome
Kyle fuller Kyle for excuse me Kyle for
the sky where I think everybody at value
but it's only been one year and they're
gone damn are we really gonna pay him 16
million dollars a year because of one
year I think also people are finally
realizing that draft picks are not
guaranteed locks right every year I have
to explain to people that well at least
they got a fifth round pick for Darren
Sproles look I'm gonna read you a list
of quality starters that were drafted in
round five in the past five draft this
is from Mike runner of PFF some amazing
name's Jordan Howard was a fifth round
pick Tyree kill Grady Jarret je je
Stefon Diggs Tell than Smith good
players the problem is is there's a list
of like 12 and what happens is we focus
on the outliers instead of looking at
the numbers right by his math it's a 7%
hit rate to get a quality starter in the
fifth round seven percent right what
happens is we go well Tom Brady was a
six right exactly yeah but our love the
NFL in rushing I bet you that no one
else in those rounds were actually
effective yeah so what happens is is
when you get a michael bennett for a
fifth round pick oh we could get a good
guy
probably not 93% of the time you're not
gonna get a quality starter and even if
he is is he gonna be as good as Michael
Bennett
that's why I'm so proud of the Browns
for actually going in there and taking
some of that equity and turning it into
players yes I think they're the 76ers
you disagree but let's get into their
moves well yeah I know what you mean
yeah okay I got you but go ahead all
right so the Browns yeah they go out
there they get Jarvis Landry right that
was the first move yeah in essence they
got him for Andy Lee and a seventh-round
pick right remember we were sitting here
going who's gonna give up to first
rounds you didn't have to they get
Jarvis Landry
Tyrod Taylor and damarious Randall get
into Danni shelter but Landry Taylor and
Randall and they gave away DeSean Kaiser
damarious Randall by the way will play
free safety the position he came out in
the draft not cornerback what did you
think about those move let's start off
with Landry and tie rod on the offensive
side I love them I love the moves they
love either guy individually right I
don't necessarily love the players but I
love the moves for where the Browns are
at in their franchise the Browns are a
team that needs some guys that have been
in a culture where they've won a little
and they can teach the rest of the young
players how to win or were the guys that
have been Browns for life who have never
won and they really don't know how and
you need that battle-tested guy so
there's there's Tyrod Taylor is he the
future of the franchise certainly not
but he did go to the playoffs this year
he was on that Ravens team that won the
Super Bowl he's played some big-time
football games so this is not his first
rodeo and he's the opposite of every
quarterback Hugh has really coached and
pretty much you're right and you know
he's been the Carson Palmer
yes I mean Andy Dalton's a little bit
mobile but yeah but he's a good player
that's gonna be able to take care of the
football
unlike DeSean Kaiser did I find the
dorsi parallel when he got to Kansas
City and was like I want Alex Smith guys
that protect the ball allow the team to
kind of run down I think we're riding
personality Landry and Josh Gordon and
if Corey Coleman can get healthy as the
three that's a really dynamic three wide
receiver sorry dynamic three and I think
that's the other thing you gotta like
about look you know Landry to being
there Landry is a tough guy he's gonna
bring an attitude to the locker room so
I look at those two moves as going their
culture changing moves they're bringing
in guys that are gonna like we're right
to compete we don't care where the damn
Browns we're coming out on this field to
win and that's what Jarvis Landry is and
Jarvis Landry what we talked about it
yeah my biggest issue was if you have to
line him outside at receiver it's not
gonna be all that good well he's done
the team that they don't have to do that
no play the slot he's gonna work the
middle and we feel Joe ku exactly Duke
Johnson they got nothing fake one yeah I
know I would love them to draft Lamar at
four underneath tie rod so it's like
ready to go and you have all those guys
yeah the question now is Hugh you we've
been able to make you've been able to
make excuses about the front office for
the last two years for the reason you've
owned one game right well now you're
gonna have weapons build an offense
around these guys don't try and force
these guys into your office exactly
right and then that's what we're seeing
with their other side of the ball that's
the other thing I like to like Denny
Shelton is not a Greg Williams guy I
know we'll talk about more than oh okay
but Damaris Randall is the perfect fit
for her great visions yes because he's
gonna go you're gonna go damn is he play
a nickel this play is he playing safety
there Blitzen they're doing all these
exotic coverages and Damaris Randall
could do all of those if something you
just don't want him on the outside on an
island Auggie and that's what we learned
in Green Bay yes but he does everything
else pretty well so I think from that
standpoint it makes a lot of sense and
then yeah when you just talk about Danny
Sheldon I don't think he's necessarily a
Greg well he's a three-four Mike Pettine
ish I saw that he played under 50% snaps
and look we've been talking about the
Patriots for a long time not having size
when they lost Allen branch at the end
of the year it was a huge issue for the
run game they've tried to figure it out
silica and all these different nose
tackles well guess what Malcolm Brown
and Danny Shelton next to each other
it's a new era for the Patriots run
defense I thought that was a great trade
to give up a 2019 third-round pick a
great trade super young still in the
rookie just on the rookie contract right
they'll be able to fit your option if
they want him around and they only to
give a rebel way what a fifth-round pick
cuz I think it was a third-round pick
next year yeah maybe you're right I
can't can't remember either way but yes
it's just such a vital part for the
success of the New England Patriots
whether it's Ted Washington win the
early Super Bowls
whether it's Vince Wilfork when they
were winning
or Allen branch here the last few years
not this past Super Bowl but the ones
before that the nose tackle gives Bella
checked the ability to do other creative
things with his front seven he can go oh
okay nose tackle I'm gonna let you two
gap so I don't have to let my
linebackers worry about this gap to the
left of this gap to the right and then
everybody else can be worried about one
single gap and Bella check as we've
talked about a million times is what a
believer in what and pass protection
pushing the pocket Danny Shelton when
you really study him pushes the pocket
and is more effective in past events
than people will give him credit for
he's just not a Greg Williams guy who I
said does exotic things he wants his
nose tackle the line of a three
technique and then slant over for gaps
to the right and they're gonna bring a
linebacker in his old gap and do things
like that and that's not what Danny
Shelton is all about Wow so I I do think
that if all those moves that Danny
Shelton ones probably the one that's
gonna have the biggest impact only NFL
next year but I do like what the Browns
have done doc alum oh my gosh yes Tom
peles arrow on NFL Network reporting
that the Vikings have reached out to
Drew Brees apparently the Vikings and
Tom GaN they've reached out to Tom
Condon they're just checking all of
their sources right there but
interesting about Drew Brees there's no
chance he doesn't I mean I mean he's
gonna he's gonna I he like if he does
III fee ends up on the Minnesota Vikings
I'll kiss your feet that guy really will
that is say for the podcast if that
happened yep we will do it I would get
on my knees and kiss your feet yeah just
your butt but that knows they're just
doing their due-diligence for that but
yeah I think the Browns the Sixers
parallels very interesting I am someone
that that
Sashi brown and Sam hinkie yeah both did
the inevitable task of losing to acquire
assets right now Sashi I don't think was
openly talking about tanking where Sam
hinkie the Sixers was openly saying it
right but they were the like the
analytics guy that came from somewhere
else that a lot of people doubted and
then the next GM in sashi's case John
Dorsey in hickeys case Bryan Colangelo
are the ones that are cashing in on all
those chips right and look like a genius
and they each took someone right before
they left so Sachi got miles garret a
stud sixers got Ben Simmons stud the
Browns have Josh Gordon a guy that
misses a lot of time but we know how
incredible and talented he is the Sixers
have joelle and beed missed a lot of
time but we know how incredibly can be
drafted on beed though right yes so
Sachi didn't draft Gordon but go ahead I
get what you mean it gives me texted
about this I wasn't know that was Friday
or Saturday night so I'm totally with
you I think this is my argument which is
with the Sasha brand cuz I've heard of
that a lot like all all these things are
happening cuz of Sasha Brown hey
certainly I'm gonna give him some credit
yes he obviously is good at wheeling and
dealing and maybe collecting assets but
that does not mean he's necessarily good
at drafting the assets after that and
that's what the whole thing for the
Sixers was is hinky is really good at
making trades and getting draft picks
for future use but is he the guy to
build the team right and that's why they
brought in Colangelo and again I'd
rather John Dorsey build my team when
you look at that Kansas City team when
they were like two three years ago as
deep as they were his thing is he just
plays it a little bit safe at the
quarterback position which is why it's
gonna be so fascinating to see what he
does it one in four yeah bills but hosts
Tyrod they trade Tyrod for the first
pick in the third round they now have to
first to second to third and the only
quarterback on their depth chart is
Nathan Peterman what do you see the
bills doing post Browns trade are they
packaging up to move up they got 21 I
don't know I have no inside info I don't
know the city I know but my guess is
because the feeling right now is they're
looking at Bradford and Keenan right but
that's not the future no but I got they
also gonna think right like we're kind
of in a win now type of mode football
team - yeah because they made the
playoffs yeah I don't know I mean they
got a lot of pieces there that you like
I think at the end of the day though
you're gonna see them make a move okay I
do I just do I I just think this is the
quarterback that fits that scheme who do
you think they move up to
it's easy they're gonna be thinking New
England right that's why I like when I
heard kids keno hmm we really would
Brian day ball wanna Case Keenum because
I know Sam Bradford's on their roster
that's about Brian day ball he was with
the Patriots and then was the Alabama
offense of course with the Patriots he
went down to the Miami Dolphins and
became the offensive coordinator there
for a little bit he came back to the
Patriots when I was there in 2012 he
came back and I think he became like the
assistant tight end coach or whatever he
was just helping out on the offenses out
of the ball right then yes he goes stays
there for a few years he is the tight
end coach in New England then goes to
Alabama becomes the Oh sounds like
everyone that coaches with New England
goes I want a taller quarterback in the
pocket package Drive the passers who can
drive the ball and have big hands that
can oh it's it's 12 degrees in Buffalo
and it's 30 mile-per-hour winds oh great
we have Tom Brady it doesn't matter he
can throw it through the wind that's
what they believe in oh great we have
Phil Simms it's the same thing right
that's the Parcells Belichick we
literally would have a sheet on our
scouting sheet to say what we expected
of the quarterback height weight hand
size all those things you weren't even
really old about the grade the
quarterback until he had those
measurable it's weird that's why the
Patriots having Brian Hoyer and the
bills supposedly interested in case came
you know it's a little different now
here is one of those wake he is a little
own lawyer has big hands it's also gonna
say go ahead roto world football tell me
the name report Jaguars interested in
Sammy Watkins yes I'm not shocked no no
not at all he better get ready for
bubble screens and slants Jacksonville
Sammy that's our quarterback Blake
bortles here's the deal
don't run further than you see David
Caldwell a few weeks ago trying to tell
people that you know he didn't do right
by play or do any favors and I wanted to
be a are you kidding me man like come on
don't to see that's like--that's David
Caldwell propaganda right there like he
didn't do right by blast outta rafters
football would kiss someone's butt to
have the things done for but Oh Allen
Robinson at the top of the second
mark Easley at the top of the second
first round left tackles top five
running back oh they do nothing for him
oh my gosh oh oh they traded it in God
what was his name Julius Thomas a tight
end oh nothing I know they've done
nothing for him I just I just hate like
that crap like okay I'm sure guy we know
that I've never seen a player have to
justify it I mean every GM in the world
would throw somebody in front of a bus
to save their jobs but this is the one
guy that people coddled well interesting
it isn't alright so on the the Tyrod
Taylor thing with him going to Cleveland
how do you think that impacts the free
agent market because that was a place
that we thought someone would go to
right but we still have case there's an
option gone the bills open up I don't
think the Brett anybody wanted to go
play for the brim you know think so this
to me this conversation didn't affect
the free agent market for quarterbacks
and just effects the draft market though
and it can change their thought in the
draft that's the first thing I thought
of now there's not necessarily the
pressure to take the quarterback at one
okay now they can go hmm we'll take sake
well Berkeley at one and then you think
I mean if Tyrod isn't the guy for the
future that takes the pressure off one
if you think the quarterbacks the guy I
think franchise that's been looking for
that guy listen at the end of the day I
still think the Cleveland Browns could
be in the position here where they get
the 1 and the 2 pick in this draft I
think they could suit either call the
New York Giants and the New York Giants
go yeah well there's nobody we love here
to write a play I know someone more yeah
right well we'll take Quintin Nelson a
four or maybe even trade down again
later and get to 8 and then trade get
Quintin Nelson whatever it may be I
think all those things are available but
I do think it takes a little pressure
off the quarterback situation to where
they just don't have to hit the bull's
eye I mean we know we want them to hit
the bull's eye yeah but there's a little
wiggle room now
yeah have a guy like tie rod in place
and I want to say this to Browns fence
look at the Jaguars yeah we sit here now
with all these rookie contracts all this
talent everyone said how did this happen
as you've said for a long time when
you're constantly picking in the top
five you accumulate some amazing town
it's not just the top five right it's at
top five of the second round the top
five of the third round I mean you're
getting pretty much two first-round
picks in a second
pick when you think about your man hinky
okay and and you're gonna hit eventually
Brad oh my Oh Ben Simmons is there with
the first monkey 610 and he jumps and
he's a great dribbler
Oh miles Garrett's they're the greatest
physical specimen ever what you're
amazing gene how did you pick him yeah
but I just go like this no one has to
suffer yes in order to get it like that
you're right your point there is right
and they are the sacrificial lambs
that's why Sixers fans say Hinke died
for our sins
that's what Sashi did I think Sashi
though I mean he just the fact that he
gave her baseball was the fact that he
was that and the fact that he passed up
some like like organization changing
quarterbacks the last two year after him
at the end
so Mike Gareth polo is saying don't wait
for Case Keenum to wait for Kirk Cousins
to sign he might actually go and sign
somewhere and not wait for Kirk because
Kirk apparently does not does not want
to pull a quote Osweiler and go and sign
with a team before he meets with them
right this is why I love Kirk Cousins
right Kirk Cousins unlike Richard
Sherman negotiating his own thing is it
a point where multiple teams are willing
to give him three years like 30 million
guaranteed and he's going oh no I'm
gonna wait I'm gonna meet with all of
you three years was 90 million so
thorough yes he is
but keenham is going I'm not waiting no
enums markets not dictated by Kirk
Cousins so he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
him he's gonna get paid less than Kirk
Cousins he knows I would think I know
this teams like the Jets are the ones
that can get screwed because if they're
trying to fight for Kirk Cousins and
their backup plan was Case Keenum
and Keenum signs with Arizona right now
the Jets are like holy crap does cousins
[ __ ] you no screw himself does he screw
himself does Minnesota start to go damn
Buffalo and the Jets are Otter offering
Case Keenum and Kirk Cousins isn't gonna
come visit to visit us for four more
days and he said he also would like to
go visit Arizona after that then you
start to go damn okay we got to make
moves so that's the other thing I'm just
interested to see I'm just being devil's
advocate I want out things like that no
I get it
oh we've we don't have a rapport we have
the the very popular I'm told
by Joe Cena Anderson Joe Cena Anderson
I'm told the Bengals are trading for
bills
tackle corty Glenn Cordy Glenn Courtney
Glenn's a hell of a tackle man he's
really he's one of the best in the sport
he really is and they have tackle issues
with the Cincinnati bag those guys they
really should because they took those
like first and second round tackles two
years ago in Jacob a shoe and a boy
right and they didn't pan out after they
lost a Whitworth they can't hide life
cycle yeah they can't so now they got a
guy Cordy Glenn is legit man he is
Justin I'm told Justin I'm told I'm told
Joe Cena if she's been told she's
usually told right right she's got a lot
of connection how much does that help
them and the bills can afford this loss
the bills cannot afford this loss
because of the kid they drafted at at
Pittsburgh Dawkins last year who ended
up filling in and playing the left
tackle I'm glad I pulled that out of my
butt that was great because I was like
oh wait who is the left but yes he did a
good job for them so they can't afford
to lose him yeah all right and then you
put Wow so Courtney Glen moving to the
left tackle for Cincinnati and they got
they got enough offensive linemen still
to be very good there I mean out of the
fact that you know Joe Mixon I mean the
Bengals are they they they got talent
yeah well they always have talented just
what are they gonna do with it
all right Patriots we already did Danny
Shelton let's stay in that AFC East in
dhama can sue
sounds like he's going to be released
lot of dead money this is another proof
that you guys should only look at the
guaranteed money what did he see of that
100 million dollar deal three years 60
million guaranteed that was all the
money that was guaranteed that's why
unless it's guaranteed you're probably
not getting it video came out of endemic
ensue working out in Seattle hmm man
would he fit the sea way from Portland
Oregon right that's very true so good
point that's part of the reason that I
think a lot of the time like the you
know again we've had this conversation
when you're the franchise player and
you're being paid more money than
anybody else on the team they want you
to be the ultimate team leader and
that's why the Eagles love your Fletcher
Cox because not only is he a killer on
the field but he does all the things off
the field as well
and in dhama can sue I think that's the
issue a little bit there he's not always
there at the facility he trains
somewhere else and they go what kind of
example is that set for your team to go
hey we'll pay you a lot of money and
then when we pay you a lot you don't
really have to come around ever except
for training camp and when the games
start so in a span of a week right
they have traded there may be their best
offensive player in Jarvis Landry and
their best defensive player in endemic
and suit this after trading their
running back in the middle of the season
and they keep saying and Dhamma kansui
sounds like it was a culture thing yeah
Landry it sounds like it was a money
thing we have been seeing people being
traded at Miami now for the better part
of two years offensive linemen middle of
the season moving linebackers and all
that what is your take on the turnover
in Miami my take is that cases case is a
tough sob and he didn't get the kind of
guys in there that he wants in there
that he fills fit his team his overall
scheme and just his mantra as a man I
mean that's really what I look at it
more than not and yeah he's trying to
eliminate some of the nonsense whether
it's you know Jarvis Landry asking for
more money in the contract details there
Lawrence Timmons gone AWOL to start of
the year you know the endowment cons
dominic ensues situations or whatever it
may be I just think he's trying to get a
team that he goes listen these are guys
I like they're reliable and they're what
I see as fit for our scheme why do you
trust Gaye so much and not go
why can't he work with any of these
athletes well I don't know if he's
necessarily can't work with them I mean
you know we're talking about three the
second year in a row in the middle of
the year or he goes this is [ __ ] I
can't handle this stuff yeah I know I
the J AJ thing listen there was
something there from the start I mean
yeah look at his legs training camps and
yes there's concerns of the knee so
that's certainly there yes and I just
think he's probably a little bit of an
old-school guy where he's like ma'am
you're walking let's get out there and
practice then so disappointing run for
endowment consumed Miami it was it was
certainly not he's still really good
he's still one of the top 10 d tackles
in football but he is not unlike aaron
Donald or Fletcher Cox's level right now
his interior d diamond and he guesses
with where who has the salary cap for
him and could use him yeah I mean you
know I got to think like team like the
cult's is gonna be think
No Domenic ensues free I mean what about
the Green Bay Packers with Mike Pettine
up there I mean I know they've had
Muhammad Wilkerson up there do the forty
niners get involved he certainly would
fit that for three Seattle type scheme
as well man I think there's a number of
teams yes it's just gonna be about maybe
the Eagles man you join Michael Bennett
and flush tops
I don't I mean the Seattle thing I know
people want to make a thing of that and
they're doing a good job of kind of
clearing their roster here but men are
they really gonna go oh we've got rid of
some of our disgruntled older defensive
veterans and get another one in here
that's kind of like that already I just
don't see that happening yeah it's
interesting because if they seem to be
going through a personality she's like
we don't we gotta get away from these
renegades a little bit and it also
sounds like they're trying to get away
from locking up too much money into like
one or two positions they want to get
back to like spread it out to all the
young guys focus on our drafting and all
that but no in donek and Sue was not a
name that I was necessarily expecting to
get cut but you could pay like three
guys with what they were paying and
diamond could sue yeah you definitely
can it's gonna be a post June 1st cut
which lessens the blow but man I mean
you look at the teams of the most money
right the Jets the Browns the cults the
Buccaneers the 49ers can you imagine if
Gerald McCoy and in dominance they
thought the same way or the same dress
all those teams have positional need
there and certainly could pay him to man
Gerald McCoy in Adamic ensue would be
that to be like John Henderson hawkish
proud Josh probably better that I used
to hate when we had to play those guys
oh my god did I hate going by I
sometimes just randomly show people the
video of John Henderson getting smacked
by the trainer yeah because I think it's
it's incredible yes you could that you
get smacked in the face now you're ready
to play those two guys are like the kind
of guys were like when you saw them
coming at you you wanted to do like
Necessary Roughness you wanted to rut
and run to the referee come down it's
over
alright so Mike Evans and Cameron Breit
are getting new contracts for the Bucks
as I mentioned calibrate it says six
years 41 million right it's 18
guaranteed okay so it's a three year six
million dollar contract it's three years
for 18 million oh you were saying this
before I forgot to Cameron Breit went to
Harvard with Kyle use check or as you
call him juicy jzj so they had both
those guys on Harvard isn't that crazy
we respect Harvard so much like as a
culture yeah that when you hear that
you're like well he probably didn't miss
that read Cameron bright knew what he
was doing Jesus was wrong it wasn't
Cameron Bray that was great they more
than Mike Evans so Mike Evans so Mike
Evans five-year only 2.5 million fifty
five guaranteed fifty-five guaranteed so
he's getting three years 18 million
basically right there yeah right you
like that signing up the weapons for
Jameis I think he's worth it I mean he's
a he is a special talent he is that size
that speed what did you think of his
play throughout the year it's hard to
diagnose him right Buccaneers receivers
because you had Fitzpatrick in there for
a lot he was kind of more notable for
diving into the back of Lattimore than
he was receiving yeah right but Evans is
a difference maker yes yes you can't you
got to be careful about how many times
you leave Mike Evans one on one Mike
Evans can really run for his size of
course his ability to jump the jump and
then you know he has a great connection
with Jameis Winston they are on the same
page they really are they've had a
connection from day one so I think
that's a smart move getting that done
now get it over but don't let him go out
there and have a big year and price
himself out that was the other thing I
will give Kyle shinny and a lot of
credit for with Marquis Goodwin
that was brilliant memory signing
Marquis Goodman did we talk about that
last week because memory signing Marquis
Goodwin I just look at it like this like
Kyle is gonna make him blow up this year
he's gonna be trying to film it yeah I
just think that's the way as often
that's the way he does it's gonna be as
Travis Benjamin it's Taylor Gabriel
whoever maybe you look through the
history of Kyle Shannon and he's always
had one of these speed Jitterbugs that
you go who the hell is this guy every
time I turn in the highlights as a 70
yard touchdown every week right might
not get the bulk of the catches and he
was amazing at the other last chance
that I mean so now he's got Jimmy G so
so okay give him three years twenty
million great because he could be on the
verge of having a year where he has 60
catches for a thousand yards and then
all of a sudden everybody's going damn
we'd like to pay him 15 million a year
and then you go [ __ ] we should have paid
him when we could him well what's
interesting about Mike Evans and paying
a player when you could same draft as
Odell Beckham Jew
Odell Beckham jr. got a little
interesting like a two-second clip went
online and the first thing I thought was
I'm wonder how our current media
landscape is gonna treat this I would
say five years ago it would be like
don't talk about it don't draw any more
attention we don't know what's going on
maybe not a lot of people saw it well
today if it's on Instagram and it's on
Twitter and it's on snapchat it's
everywhere and now I'm listening to our
guy Leba tarde and our lawyers are
telling us we have to call it a white
powdery substance because you don't know
what that is and he's smoking a brown
cigarette and you don't know what that
is the only thing we can say is that he
had pizza in the room everyone's saying
well what do you think about this what
do you think it was in Paris France and
you got takeout pizza that's the most
disappointing thing in LA that's I mean
it's old Gabe saying it's old because
he'd have risk tattoos in the video my
thing to this is always this I could
take a two-second clip of anybody when
they're out and make it look like
they're having the craziest thing ever I
am NOT going to as hosts of the players
podcast indict anybody on charges that I
have no proof on and then I have no idea
or any context of what happened right
but what happens is it turns into a
little story like this and you want to
pay him big money and he's putting
himself into situations like that I
don't really think he put himself into
situations I know a lot of people that
don't do drugs that are sometimes around
drugs sure I have a lot of friends never
smoked in their life but have a lot of
friends that smoke
I never done whatever been around people
that do write self control all that
stuff I just it's very interesting how
every time Odell does anything if he's
dancing he doesn't take football serious
you know like we're always looking for a
way to remove him from that payday and I
also thought what's very interesting is
I'm looking at a lot of GM's look at
salaries as percentage of total cap not
comparing you because to compare Odell
to Antonio's contract two years ago is
costing Odell money from the salary cap
that's gone up - yes right he's gonna
get paid around 18 to 20 million a year
yeah so I mean if if Mike Evans is
getting 18 million a year Odell Beckham
jr. just hurts more I could yeah
how what did you think of the video what
did you think of the reaction to this
two things right away
Gabe our cameraman over here what
gaybies Johnny giant fan okay he knows
everything and Gabe was trying to say
Gabe I didn't hear this theory but I
wish you would have told me this for
eight that he's missing he doesn't have
a wrist tattoo in the video that he does
have now you're saying that's interest
and he did tweet out something about old
news or this being like in somebody
doing this so I thought it'd be
interesting to see I'll say this though
for this this this point you know
anybody just listen to the the Simpson
left kopaka snows
I love Odell Beckham jr. so does let go
we love him I want to see him be paid
accordingly as like one of the best
players in football he deserves
quarterback type money I mean good
starting quarterback type money but I'll
say this it does bother me
it really does he's got to show better
judgment I don't really care what you
say if you want to be one of the
greatest sports stars in the world and
you want to be LeBron James or you want
to be Michael Jordan or Cristiano
Ronaldo who I also saw Odell looking at
his Bugatti this weekend too if you want
to be those things those guys don't have
videos out there with brown cigars
substances and white powder substances
right they are the face of the franchise
their faces of many other organizations
that are trying to sell things as well
if Odell Beckham jr. wants more money
from Nike he can't be in videos like
that because again you're gonna have
parents who are gonna go I'm not buying
my son Odell Beckham jr. Jersey or I'm
not gonna buy his Nike cleat as a person
who roots for Odell Beckham jr. I just
wish he didn't do that because at the
end of the day he's only gonna hurt
himself yeah so apparently my Internet's
not working can you open that door just
to see if we can get some internet in
here but apparently the deal on the core
D Glenn is that core Teague the Bengals
are going to swap pics with the bills
and the Bengals are just going to take
on a salary so that's the trade they're
swapping first-round picks so the bills
are gonna move up to where the bengals
worth that bangles have the 12th pick in
the draft
so my internet works i know how to use
it a little better than you
chut I'll let you know the login
sometime to go for so this is this is
amazing we were just talking about this
we're going how are the bills gonna move
up in the draft will they get rid of
Cordy Glenn and what happens is is they
move from 21 to 12 so now they have 12
and 22 Alvin 20 this is very similar to
what the Eagles did to go up and get
cookie turn your audio off oh yeah you
really know how to use your internet but
the Eagles are not legal what go to a
page and it can start spewing out voices
and like that shouldn't be allowed but
the Eagles traded up from I think it was
13 to 8 right when they gave up Byron
Maxwell in Kiko Alonso to put them in
position to move up to 2 with the Titans
to take carson wentz and it looks like
the bills are doing that right now
the bills are doing them you like that
move I know you like Cordy Glenn but I
guess that you like the guy behind him
enough to I I do and I do like them I
like the moves from the buffalo bill
standpoint for sure yes 9 spots is
valuable 9 spots is extremely valuable
the other thing I just want to look up
to just to see is what kind of money
korte Glenn I have every 4:30 so he's
getting paid 10 million a year yeah yeah
this year I mean he's he's a fourteen
million dollar cap hit this year so yes
that's that's a fair trade all right I
want to talk about something that is
football but not football Monday Night
Football we are having a completely new
announcing team in the booth if you
listen to this show you know that I was
not even though he went to Syracuse like
I did I was not the biggest fan of Sean
McDonough I did not find the rapport
between him and Jon Gruden to be any
good ESPN releases the news saying that
he's super excited to go back to college
football and they're gonna replace him
with Joe tessitura
and we do not know the other names that
are gonna be in the booth it did come
out that Peyton Manning was willing to
do the booth if they could somehow get
Mike Tirico so Peyton Manning came in
and said I don't I'll do it just get a
guy from a different network to come in
and do it all in the face of NBC sure go
ahead
but I I look at Joe des auteur and great
guy I'm not the biggest fan of him doing
college football not at all I just find
him to be kind of a little corny and
Joe tessitura here and what do you know
Virginia Tech established in 1945 like
it's it's so like Joe tessitura with
Keith Jackson right there was about to
go like whoa Nellie I did test tweet
earlier Southern California Trojans
there was old that I can't do a testator
I lost him I was doing him earlier do
you think opera that's what I always
think yeah so you told me that his dad
was in the Opera dad was in the Opera
yes and you actually when you auditioned
with ESPN right it was with Tessa pool
is the wit tessitura all right Chris
Sims he did he was all over and he was
he was even giving me some techniques of
that had a talk and breathe as you talk
and I mean he's really a professional at
it I'm with you I like Joe since a tour
but I'm not a huge fan of his voice as
it pertains the football I just can't
believe he's Monday Night Football
I like him in boxing I guess they don't
got anybody else though I mean who does
it who does they got I mean the only guy
the guy wasn't McDonagh and they they
train I like the guy that does she was
McDonough I know you did I did not
yeah I just found him to not be great
and I found it that was amazing but I
look at you knew I liked the doctor guy
that does college basketball with Billis
Dave okay remember his name yeah I know
I think he does he does Major League
Baseball for ESPN oh he does yes I can't
think of his name but I mean Monday
Night Football was defined by Gruden for
almost a decade and now I just don't
know where they're going
no I just not and then yeah I'll be
interested to yes me and uh sounds like
they're in a tough spot
well I've read the thing to online that
I saying that the ESPN and in the NFL
were a little bit at odds over certain
things too so it'd be interesting to see
where this contract situation goes when
it's all up it's really interesting
alright so of all the other moons hey
this is exciting breaking news period I
told you it was gonna be a freaking 40
Glenn any of these other things mean
anything to you Titans cut DeMarco
Murray he's meeting with the Lions
49ers cut Elvis do Merville Steve
gentlemen going and getting a toga ultry
and sort of trying to build the Carolina
defense there Casey Heyward gets a new
contract any of that stick out Casey
like one of the better players in all of
football and the defensive side that
nobody really knows about I mean he was
really good with the Green Bay he went
to the Los Angeles chargers first the
San Diego Chargers and really became a
better player when he was there as well
but the elbow tree things interesting to
me left go for this for this reason the
Giants have three needs in my eyes it
could be an offensive lineman a middle
linebacker and probably your running
back and now you've taken away one of
those needs right with this trade and
getting Ogletree and Ogletree is gonna
be perfect fit for their defense and
what James Boettcher wants to do he's
gonna be like their Ryan shazier but to
me it does single out now for me or the
Giants where I look at it and go do they
take say Kwan Barclay a 2 or do they
trade down and take Quentin Nelson I
really think it's a two horse race
they're okay and I'll be interested to
see if a Cleveland or somebody comes in
there say qualms Barclays for the first
time I can ever remember is a legitimate
first pick of the draft at the running
back position not only terms of
perception or his talents all the talent
for one the talent is special like I
said he's he's as good as I've ever seen
on film he really isn't I think he's
made for the NFL I mean made for it he's
gonna be better in the NFL than he was
in college he could quite arguably he is
the type of talent to where he could be
the best player in the NFL next year
that's what counted he is but also he's
an old-school throwback to the franchise
running back before we had the franchise
quarterback he's he could be the Earl
Campbell Walter Payton let's say bo
Jackson first pick of the draft from the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers where his off the
field is squeaky clean he's got a
million-dollar smile yes everything
about him is right he is the type of
running back we're a team I go you know
what screw it let's make him the number
one pick so I just think it's
interesting to look at go I think fans
have heard for so long that the running
back position isn't that important and
when I talk to like yeah but a running
back because that's the media they've
consumed for so long but when it's that
good yes and I just I look at the Browns
and I go man tie rods
and Landry and Josh Gordon and can Corey
Coleman and Joe ku and Duke Johnson like
what are you gonna do I know and then
the giant she's good already - and they
got more money to spend so they get one
of these corners and free agency I mean
watch out I mean like is it really a
watch out like are we just getting too
hype about the Browns right now or is
this a legitimate watch I think the
talent is getting there to where we're
getting we have some ants unanswered
questions right we need to see Corey
Coleman healthy we think he's going to
be good but we haven't really get to see
you yet yes we got to see Josh Gordon
just stay on the roster and stay on the
team stay eligible but yes there's
potential there it's really I think just
about can you can you teach those guys
to get over the edge and win some games
do you think that Joe Thomas is looking
at this even though he's contemplating
retirement be like how am I gonna miss
out on this yeah I sure the hell hope he
plays I really do I mean I just he's
gonna be a first-ballot hall-of-famer at
the left tackle position what he's done
is amazing and they don't get him
they're going Nate's older I mean that's
who they're gonna go after so I'm sure
they think so yeah I do I think that's I
mean I think it's been out there too
I've read it on a few things over the
weekend so I'm sure they would like an
answer from Joe here shortly so they can
make the appropriate play all right so
guys I know a lot of you that are
watching the podcast you used to watch
it on my channel we are now on the
bleach report Channel so hello to all
the bleacher report YouTube subscribers
YouTube subscribe and all that stuff on
my own personal channel the Adam left
Cole one that is where we are gonna do
iTunes comments that's where we're gonna
do a little offshoot videos and if we
end up doing any film rooms stuff like
that I'm gonna definitely post them over
there but we're on Bleacher Report now
so a lot more people are seeing us hey I
don't know if you've heard were kind of
big dimer as you thinking of kind of Big
Time yeah on Wednesday yes Sims and
myself we are headed to Miami welcome to
Miami and the needle ami ami Sims is
going to be on the Leba tarde show to
give his top six quarterbacks the final
six after calling Blake bortles number
70 it's been three months in the making
holy crap it's crazy and
after that we are going to be having
Leba tarred and stugots on the sims and
left go podcast we're gonna try and get
that out Wednesday night we're super
excited about it yeah and because we're
very well aware that a lot of news is
gonna happen between now and Wednesday
Thursday we're gonna come in and we're
gonna record on a free agency update and
that will come out Friday morning to
give you guys some stuff for the weekend
but your guys now on the stugots know
what if I when I get in there I'm just
gonna be staring them down and anytime
they ask me a question I'll be like you
like that chair it's a pretty good chair
I get sitting that chair when I'm most
to God like I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna slowly get up guys thank you so
much as always hit us up on social at
Sims and Lefko whether it's the podcast
whether it's Twitter whether it's
Instagram hit us up and we're gonna be
recording some iTunes comments later in
the week for simps peace out homies
Bendrick would say goodies go Bundrick
and the lef koe man says good night
hopefully free agency is good for you
and your team and you spend money wisely
well holler at you with Levitt Arden's -
gots coming up later this week